oh gobble it
i wouldn't think twice at that point if
i'm three days deprived bro
i'll gobble it
[Music]
what is going on party people we are
back again for another
fresh and funky monday yo yo if you are
watching on the youtube you may be
looking at me thinking james what's
going on with your head top j money's
trim is a bit late yeah j money usually
comes with that hard and fresh but today
he's looking a bit
leaving a bit question of it leave it
leave it
[Laughter]
do you remember that
we've given that guy far too much
attention on this show i swear to god
um so yeah my head top is looking a bit
leave it um
not only is my birmingham barber not
available for the the sacred monday trim
that i usually always get before we
record
on top of that my barber at home
is also unavailable
and even the second string barber at the
birmingham shop wasn't available until
after this recording so here i am head
top looking chew out drapes nappy
whatever you want to call it yeah
i've kind of held mine down like mine is
probably like a week old or so but
i've tried to keep it stunned but you
know it's it's gonna need a trim next
week but this time next week your boys
will be fresh oh next this time next
week your boys will be next time you see
us you'll be globbing yeah so just be
ready for that but for the time being
yeah i'm just going to hold that all the
l my head is chew out my beard it's just
flagrant it's just doing what it wants
i'm stressed about it but hey it is it
is what it is man
if you always look buff then you kind of
never look buff true do you know what i
mean it's true true there's no like wow
yeah if you're not gonna if you're not
willing to collapse sometimes then you
can never really look back yeah there's
no one fact i mean there's nothing
that'll be like oh wow oh wow look you
look fire yeah there's nothing you're
just the same you plateaued yeah exactly
so yeah your boy's willing to take the l
so i can look buff next time so there
you go
um
as always guys you already know what to
do you're here with us now thanks but
quickly while you've got a minute pause
the episode head on over to
patreon.com forward slash sheets and
gigs we are slowly becoming the biggest
and best patreon in the world is that a
fact yes it is is anyone willing to
admit no
but we know the truth we actually know
the truth yeah we actually do they've
sat us down and said to us guys you
changed the game you have changed the
game we can't expose this to anyone else
but just so you're aware
patreon exclusive human adult you mind
the best yeah
you are doing a different thing and it's
not making sense but we don't want to
change it um
so guys head on over there we've got
over like at this point we're at like
two and a half years worth of content
over there that you can binge or know a
lot of you guys love to binge through it
um it's only going to cost you three
pound a month 10p a day quickly run the
p over to us and then gain access and
then come and funk with us every
thursday
and if you're bad you jump on that tier
two you're getting the zoom calls once a
month once a month you can see how we're
doing ask us what's going
face a little back and forth for
friendly chin wag meet the community
over there yeah man um yeah man
everyone's having a great time yeah yeah
so
guys heading over there if you are
listening on spotify if you're listening
on
apple podcast if you're listening on
itunes if you're listening to amazon
music google podcast wherever you like
listen to your podcast um
please leave a nice
five star review if you're feeling
generous but i'll take anything at this
point
um let's spread the word let the cult
grow white robes and yeezys are affluent
at this point yeah ma'am yeah man that's
the uniform that's the uniform and if
you're not on board then you're against
it you know the vibes um so guys let us
rack up the members rack up the breeding
grounds someone asked us um
are homosexuals allowed in the breeding
grounds or what as well i was like
everyone's included love is non-binary
brother everything there's no judgment
there's literally no judgment in the log
cabin it's for humans
bro it's for homo sapiens you're always
involved are you part of mother earth
yes yes come on in then run it up don't
ask silly little questions bruh run it
up and come back
in there
yeah bro oh that's what we do um
yeah so guys come and join us at the log
cabin man you'll see your two where the
two door men to the rest of you are
checking every man in yeah yeah you've
got to leave on the list you have to be
on the list you can't just try and hide
your win
you know uh we know so anyway guys
slight tangent get back to it if you're
watching on youtube like the episode
chapstick in the comments subscribe to
the channel get the notifications on
without any further ado
my main man my best friend my compadre
my amigo hey
mia moore
fun fact of the day fire lord fuegs so
let's go as i'm sure everyone in the
world knows um
the unfortunate mass shooting that
happened in texas a few weeks back yeah
yeah so i saw this unfathomable stat the
other day
and i couldn't believe it
i couldn't believe it
so this was posted on the 24th of may
2022
today is a hu today is the 144th day of
2022. the avalde shooting is the 212th
mass shooting of 2022. no it's not just
in america
212th mass shooting mass in america
shoot this year this [ __ ] year that's
impossible
this year
that's physically impossible wild that
is that's actually impossible what what
did you define mass so that's what i was
looking at earlier so i think mass
shooting is anything above it's like got
three above three or four above yeah so
i was looking at it earlier and i looked
at the maps let me show you
on the map on all the dots
fam
is it all over is it is it local oh it's
localized let me see this not like i
understand where any of these places are
central america's chilling
these shores these shores i guess
yeah yeah
i tried to be funny yeah your sensitive
tongue just shut yourself up yeah it's
not a time for jokes it's not a time i
mean it's always the time for jokes but
it's literally not a time for jokes
[ __ ] me nuts brother
200 something this year this year cuz
there's been more my shootings than it
has
days in this year it's just
perplexing to me that's too much isn't
it
come on guys that's a bit too much it's
like what what goes through man's heads
over there like it's clear that bullets
sorry
that's a that's a ricky gervais type
thing that's a dave chappelle type thing
fair [ __ ] play you were quick quitted
and quick
i'm sorry i couldn't
physically resist sorry
yeah
yeah
i they need to do something about these
gun laws bruv that's
obviously we i say we but people talk
about this day in day out week and week
out about their gun laws and stuff but
it's clearly never going to change
there's too many people in in position
of power that just want to they're about
it they just want to have that over over
america
yeah it's a weird one as i said i don't
know man it's a it's a very i've
listened to a lot of perspective on it
it's a very tough nut to crack of course
it is um there's so many people are pros
so many people are four against sorry
and some people are just in the middle
yeah exactly and it's it's part of their
like this is
one of their amendments gene it's just
like it's why they're human rights over
there yeah they're they're they're
they're they're they're no they're
entitled to have guns yeah and it's it's
oh in america the tough thing in america
is is there's more guns than there are
people there's no facts yeah i knew that
so at this point
even if they changed the law and was
like no one's allowed guns
where you get like unless you're gonna
start knocking everyone's house and said
run your guns give me a gun but run me
my refund also yeah exactly you have to
buy the gun from you you literally can't
sell if someone's purchased something
you can't just tell them you have to get
rid of it like if they purchase it
legally they have to they have you you
have to buy it from them yeah so you're
not gonna be they're not going to buy
them from
what's the it's not a market it's the
what's the word i'm looking for no it's
a market it's a market yeah yeah
it's it's like it's an economy
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah uh
stock over there yeah yeah but also like
there's there's no way to pattern it and
plus even if in a perfect world they
were like all right everyone get ready
with guns and then every quad law
abiding citizen was like all right say
less
criminals are still going to keep their
guns yeah so then all of a sudden now
you're just in a position where only
criminals have guns and police officers
and police officers it's just going to
spike people are just going to be
getting shady guns for everywhere
it's um
it's too yeah yeah unless they're gonna
oh [ __ ]
unless they're all gonna relocate to a
different continent and they're not
allowed to bring their guns with them
yeah that's the only way it's gonna get
patterned so it's mad man it's just a
tough one i think it obviously there's a
large debate over there about kind of i
think the mayor the more relevant debate
that they have over there is like the
access
to guns because obviously a lot of the
people that are doing these mass
shootings are usually like young people
with like severe [ __ ]
clearly mental issues so it's like what
is like i think a lot of the debate is
like figuring out the screening process
yeah see the accessibility of these man
with guns so you can get guns in that
walmart and stuff can't you yeah that's
an imagine got bopping into asda and
just seeing an isle of guns
yeah like family
yeah it's long
uh it's long
yeah man
um speaking of what you said about the
ricky gervais thing i was watching the
ricky gervais his new stand up this is
nature yeah
i saw it the i'm sorry when i was in
london yeah he doesn't play he doesn't
play with his words
he doesn't play any he rarely misses
he loves being rich as well
he does he just throws it in there he
[ __ ] loves it
um but yeah i enjoy i haven't finished
it yet i've got like 20 minutes left but
i have been enjoying it because like
yeah it's like it is very just like
he he also did the same thing in his
last special but it's just like
hammering home like yeah
be offended if you want to be offended
but just shut up and i'm including
everyone yeah i mean
anyone can literally get it so him and
like dave chappelle they're like the two
are the same yeah they're truly the same
and they just include everyone yeah and
there's always a message behind what
they're saying yeah you just have to
read between the lines yeah it's funny
but read between the [ __ ] lines yeah
man it's just i'm trying to paint a
picture here yeah yeah it's it's tough
but anyway right after an appalling
pulling pulling first effort from us oh
god we're gonna try a second attempt we
tried this first of all on patreon and
it went horrifically well i don't know
if we had to privy to our patreon
comments because i used to do most of
the advent on there i've seen it but
they've been abusing them on there yeah
i couldn't care less
i have a sharp or arrest me one of the
two
what you did to darth vader
sacrilege
either shut up or arrest me um
right
so
the aim of the game guys if you don't
know is you pick a character and you
pick a scenario
and then the other person has to guess
who the character is and what the
scenario you're trying to do is by you
impersonating
this thing
and as you can imagine i was terrible at
it oh if i just put these on the top
yep
it's the same problem from last time
yeah
it just doesn't help that the box is so
awkward to deal with it just doesn't
incentivize you to shuffle these [ __ ]
cards at all
right so
let's start off with
one round each there
and one round each
here
right the rules are
it doesn't matter if you find it
difficult yeah but if i don't know the
person if you don't know the person you
can you can swap but i'll keep the
scenario but if you as long as you know
the person yeah
you have to try [ __ ] sake i know you
hate it if you bought the [ __ ] game i
know it could sound like a cool game
right i'll go first
it's cool
ah these [ __ ] bonus cards bro
let me make sure i got a bonus
oh and i've wow i've done this one
really yeah it was the same one as
before oh god give me strength this
game's cursed yeah this game's cursed
it's tough we've played a lot of games
in that time this game's [ __ ] cursed
we can't get like
a [ __ ] break you've not had that one
no you've had this one
i'm tired of this
oh my god i've had this one i did that
one the first time
what's going on guys bro this game's
cursed
okay all right okay
okay
okay
um
oh my god
all right
what the [ __ ] was that right okay
[Music]
all right cool
right i'll do the impression okay
that's not the impression this woman i
know okay sorry
give me a c
what is a spell
abc
oh i really hope i make the team
i did the best i could i know i know i
know i know
[ __ ]
as soon as you started it reminded me of
someone but i already once he did the
hooting
i completely knew it wasn't him who i
was thinking of but i can't remember who
the other brother is
when you started it reminded me of um
the brethren family guy the
the creepy old guy that likes um chris
no not him but you know you know what
i'm talking about i know he's old fart
yeah yeah yeah
you want a clue
not yet all right
oh actually uh yeah wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait is it a disney
character yeah yeah it's um
it's um it's donald duck no
goofy it's one of them it's one of them
[ __ ]
it's one of them it's a disney character
mickey yeah mickey sorry yeah donald
duck
mickey singing the alphabet no no no
give me a give me a b give me c what
that's about abc
um
mickey mouse
[ __ ] you're on the edge bro you're doing
well
um
i do live with mark
go
welcome
[Laughter]
i knew that it threw me but i couldn't
remember where i heard it from mickey
[ __ ] mouse well [ __ ] played say
less gang that's well played to you bro
you're the actor here
i'm just guessing [ __ ]
see it's this scenario i i think i've
i've got the the character down okay the
scenario all right
okay i'm ready
hello
hello
i'd like to
hello i'd like to sell you this
this cup this
this this cup is
is the best cup you'll ever see
it's the best cup you'll ever drink from
um
jesus
um
the joker no no no no no you're far off
that's my fault no no it's all right um
right are you a daughter salesman
you're in the realm but i'm not a
door-to-door salesman but you're in the
realm all right um keep going
okay um give me a sec there's
he's got something that's very
prominent i'm trying to remember what it
is
hey bro this is the best cup you will
ever see
it has
a wide circle
it has
a lot of depth no pun intended
and
that's part of it
are you [ __ ]
scooby doo bro yes i am all right
say less a less [ __ ]
i thought you were scooby doo yeah the
first time you said harold yeah
and then when you started describing the
cup the first time you sounded like
heath ledger's joker the cop threw me i
picked the first thing all right but yes
i am scooby okay scooby-doo
um
selling sighting fam yeah
is the cup relevant
no it could be anything so you'll just
scoop it as a salesman
i'll give you a point and a half is
scooby-doo selling a new miracle product
on an infomercial i was never going to
even
fam exactly and you're so specific that
is very [ __ ] specific right let's try
one more each jesus that was hard man
this game is [ __ ] difficult bro it's
the toughest thing
oh
oh i don't even know what he sounds like
[ __ ] this is going to be hard hmm yeah
um yeah
um
sit down little kiddies
yeah
um
let me uh
let me uh read you something
yeah
um
one day um myself and
miss piggy um
yeah we were uh walking down the yellow
brick road
yeah is this
ah
is it the is this car is the car
character
oh
that's annoying i genuinely thought i
knew he was um
keep going
okay is the scenario something to do
wizard of oz
no oh sure kind of right no no it's not
okay cool
yeah um
so
um let me uh i can't give it away like
that um
let me keep reading this to you yeah
um
in the hope that uh you'll get a little
bit sleepy
yeah um hopefully miss piggy can come
and help and um [ __ ]
i know this voice i know this style of
speaking i don't know who it is
uh you're doing really well but i just
the person is coming to my head think
about who the other person i'm
referencing is yeah miss piggy obviously
so who is that
who is miss piggy
okay okay okay okay okay okay that's why
you said okay yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
um is his name elmo no no but nearly
sesame street bread i wanted them it's
not sesame street uh you're on the wrong
right line yeah yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] uh
so think of a different puppet show
that's not sesame yeah [ __ ]
um [ __ ]
[ __ ]
um
um oh
this is so old yes it's old [ __ ]
um miss piggy yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah what are we looking for no it's not
grouch that's the not oscar the grouch
it's um
street it's the yeah that's just some
[ __ ] as well [ __ ] so i think um
yeah so my best friends are miss piggy
and yeah
um
we
[ __ ] i'm so annoyed
the ghost of christmas past
um
who the [ __ ] is even else in this show
[ __ ] man
you quit
let me try and get the scenario though
okay at least so i'll keep going right
yeah
so uh let me keep reading and hopefully
you guys will fall asleep um
saying a bedtime story yes
um [ __ ] who is this bread are you i know
i know i think i know this you're going
to be [ __ ] vegan
you know who it is yeah yes miss piggy
oh
[ __ ] i give up kermit the frog kermit
the [ __ ] frog brother
well play though you did well you didn't
save g
you did very well
very [ __ ] well yeah oh that's jokes
i'm not going to lie to you james i
don't know how to do this brother
i'm not even going to sit here and cat
right
do your best and then do what i did and
give me
surrounding references
yeah yeah okay cool right
sorry excuse me excuse me guys sorry
excuse me guys victoria hurry up my
seats are over there seats are over
there sorry guys i just need to use my
um i should use my torch to cause i
can't really see where i'm going
just sorry guys sorry guys um
[Music]
victoria guys romeo come on guys our
seats are over there come on
victoria
david beckham
um
finally in the cinema in a dark cinema
all right yeah
[ __ ] hell fan you're saying victoria
i'm thinking
who
the [ __ ]
is that
that's what i'm saying i don't know what
you sound oh bro
he's not going to distinguish yeah
kind of but how do you even
say how did you actually miss out but
yeah
god i hate that game bro [ __ ] me really
[ __ ] the amount of pressure i feel
when i look at these cars and have to
read them out bro
[ __ ] hate first impressions yeah
you're right you're really good at them
oh [ __ ] the um the um the characters are
really good at them really good of them
bro
because i i i hone into what they're who
they're meant to be yeah i just can't
sometimes i don't remember them like the
darth vader one [ __ ] you now bruv the
bane.vet i was like i know this voice
bro i know this voice
you know
and this coming frog i knew the voice oh
bro you did it yeah you did very well
james well played
[ __ ] me
right but yeah guys let us know if you
got any of those at home if you
if you understood the voice and stuff
especially if you're listening on the
audio let me know if you got that as
well yeah let us know in the comments
for sure
okay right so i have and am i the
[ __ ] oh nice hit me
so let's check it out oh okay guys so
i'm id awesome
i was seeing this guy last year july
jesus you good yeah i just burped
well seeing this guy last year july
and things moved so fast because of the
great connection we had
[Music]
sorry
um by mid mid-august we had already met
went on dates met his friends and stayed
at each other's houses and had banging
sex all the time
so things seemed quite serious however
he kept he kept saying he's not about
this whole relationship thing but if it
happens it happens
that doesn't make sense
do you mean if it happens it happens
he's he's not on it it's a conscious
decision yeah yeah if it happens it
happens means he's waiting for you to
say
why for me then and then he's just like
me or i'm leaving yeah yeah yeah babes i
like you summer bb finance yeah yeah
yeah pressure
so so i decided to go with the flow
now as things are um
now as things are serious he tells me
okay sorry i can't [ __ ] read this
properly is there punctuation no yeah
right
now as things are serious he tells me he
lips the girl at a party
i'm confused but not surprised
but also pretty mad because things were
going so good with him
i've learned my lesson in the past to
not be a [ __ ] and get treated like
[ __ ] without dishing
dishing it out back
so i call one of my ex tings in brackets
he's toxic
and we end up [ __ ] oh we go
she must have gone wet from the jump bro
time goes by and i'm still with the guy
from july and i haven't told him about
my ex i found out my ex thing caught
chlamydia
by someone he [ __ ] after me
and it was funny to me so i decided to
wait till his birthday
comment under his birthday post happy
birthday chlamydia boy
this is the toxic thing this is the
toxic thing oh wow you shouldn't even be
chatting to him
you just that was a one-night and leave
what you're all commenting chlamydia
[ __ ] under his post okay continue bro
his things and his boys saw it and told
him then he done some fbi [ __ ] fouled
out it was me because it was the same
phone number
so now he's mad and he decides to send
mike my current man from july a message
to say that i'm a cheat
rax you are my current team gets mad and
ends up blocking me etc am i the [ __ ]
for [ __ ] my ex because of the
because of the kissing
here we go here we go here's the
justification bearing in mind i don't
need to bear anything in mind because
i've read the whole time yeah yeah yeah
you're a cheat and you're a liar yeah
bearing in mind he expressed many times
he didn't want a relationship so he
shouldn't be that mad
shut up
no no no you're an [ __ ]
you're an also yes you're an [ __ ]
because
um you [ __ ] with this other brother
you're also an [ __ ] for typing this
whole
bruv brav rav there's so many reasons
why you're an artist bro i'm not hit you
literally said
i'm not here to be treated like a
[ __ ] and not dish it back
what is that that's an [ __ ] movie are
you do you want a relationship or not do
you want a relationship or not are you
are you just in the streets
because that sounds like you're in the
streets to me that sounds like you want
a man but you want to do what you want
to do as well yeah yeah yeah yeah so
you're you're not clearly in the right
frame you're right
exactly that's not a relationship-based
thing you're on a tit for tattooing we
don't run it for tat not in this not in
sng studios not anywhere no we don't run
a a point scoring no you're an [ __ ]
yeah you are that doesn't just and just
because we're calling you ours it
doesn't contain any anything anyone else
is doing yeah it's just your actions are
[ __ ] moves bro facts the fact that
you're commenting on your
toxic toxic exes
saying happy perfect
boy
this is a bread that you [ __ ] was mad
at your ma
boyfriend yeah because he lit someone
else he lit someone else so you revenge
[ __ ] your ex and then found it funny
to comment on your ex's post saying
happy birthday media boy you deserve
everything that you got and you have the
audacity to ask us if you're the [ __ ]
and still send that in with chest oh the
most chest and said bear in mind that he
did this than that and that he said it
doesn't relationship he shouldn't even
be mad because of xyz
you said you were mad because he lit
someone i've said this so many times and
i'll say it again for the people in the
back a lot of you man type stuff in rage
and don't read it back
because if you took five minutes or send
that to one of your boys or girls and
ask them what do you think of what i'm
about to send to these pretend this
wasn't me read it read it and give me
your point of view bro i found this on
reddit let me know what you think yeah i
found this on reddit let me know what
you think because you will be [ __ ]
surprised what your friends will tell
you you're crazy
you're [ __ ] crazy what do you mean
oh brav nah man no that's not that's not
on you're an [ __ ] yeah you're moving
like an arsenal yeah that's arsenal
moves if you
you can't back a man in a corner and say
pretty much say if you don't want to be
with me
leave me
but then pressure him into relationship
and then be mad that he lip someone and
take revenge by [ __ ] your ex and then
scheming on your ex as well for no your
ex is minding his business you hollered
him yeah you shouted him he banged you
he left and moved on with his life and
then you think it's funny to goad him in
his birthday points call them chlamydia
boys birthday post
you get all you deserve yeah you got the
comeuppance on that one you get all you
literally you literally got your
comeuppance on that i'm sorry it had to
be you but you literally got what you
deserved i'm not sorry you deserve that
i'm not sorry you did deserve it to be
fair
[ __ ] you now yeah that's a tough one
that was actually juicier than i than i
originally expected when i read it i
just i briskly read over it before um
but i didn't i didn't i didn't deep it
properly yeah that's [ __ ] moves bro
big big boy sorry for that but that's
that's
big man [ __ ] it doesn't make sense
i'm not a fan of that behavior it
doesn't in the slightest sense brother
what's up guys all right let's take a
little break from the episode and let's
shed some love on our boys and girls
over at man escaped guys you already
know the deal you already know how this
goes
if you've been with us up until now you
already know how much we love manscaped
but
have we told you about their fourth
generation trimmer yes i know we have
but let's talk it again it features
cutting edge ceramic blade to reduce
grooming accidents thanks to their
advanced skin safe technology tm bro
come on the lawnmower 4.0 is waterproof
has a 400k led spotlight it's blindingly
bright [ __ ] um
and uh
as you know guys father's day is round
the corner and it's right
bro it's just round the bend literally
does your dad use the same trimmer for
his body and face he probably does
probably he's an old man he doesn't know
what he's doing he's senile
throw it out the window and give him the
upgrade he deserves max plus guys
there's more manscape just launched
their brand new boxes 2.0
i say the best boxes ever i think i do
guys we all know dads love their comfort
yes with summer just around the corner
as well the boxers 2.0 are here to save
every father from the uncomfortable heat
guys and if you want to get involved all
you need to do is head on over to
manscape.com
code is sng sierra november golf
20 off that will get you as well as free
shipping
worldwide one more time for the
nosebleeds
far far far at the back is manscape.com
code is sng sierra november golf 20 of
free shipping head on over get a patent
and then we can get back to the episode
thank you very much
all right cool trash news
trashy trash let me just pull the thing
up sir right
you might like this one as well because
you know about this guy you follow him
all right
so youtuber mr beast
paid someone
7650 pounds a day to live in a prison
have you heard about this no i have not
yeah yeah yeah yeah cool safe safe safe
safe let me give you the the full
context
so josh rock who is the lead video
editor for mr beast's youtube channel
according to instagram was tasked to was
tasked with remaining in a confined
space for a hundred days however rock
managed a respectful 21 days banging him
sorry banking him 340 thousand dollars
equivalent to 260 000 pounds
viewers were quick to accuse the content
creator of damaging rock's mental health
thanks to prison like said since
thanks to the prison-like setting
however responding to the backlash rock
said i was never in any danger
physically or mentally the video titled
ten thousand dollars every day you
survived prison has now been viewed over
38 million times on mr beast's youtube
channel do you think you can take this
challenge
yeah
i'll at least make it one day that's for
sure the
just a confined room just a four by four
nothing in there just nothing just you
and a bear damn it
yeah i need my lap
and probably a paste a place to piss or
[ __ ]
because there's fam there's no clocks
there's no windows there's just a lot oh
you don't even know what time it is it's
an asylum yeah
it's basically an asylum
bro i'm not gonna lie to you
that would be tough he made it 21 days
21 days that's a long [ __ ] time three
weeks
um wow that is a long time i think if i
can am i love books
um if i'm the um adjudicator i would say
yes you're allows anything hardcopy
you're not allowed electronics online
mm-hmm so because you couldn't with
electrons you can see the time yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah i think i'd be on a old boy thing
and i'd still need to watch that movie
[ __ ] the company no no no no no no no no
um
yeah i'd need to designate routines in
my life
when i wake up i do this
and then i read
like i want to try and get through like
this much then i take a nap
then i read some more then i work out
then i do this and i need routine in my
life i literally need routine in my life
and i need to stick to these things
every day
and get through it
until i can't get through it anymore i'm
like this is [ __ ] dead now i need to
go i think the only time you'll probably
realize what kind of time of the day is
is when they bring you food yeah yeah
that's the only point of reference point
of reference you would get yeah yeah
and
personally i don't think i'll make it a
day
you don't think you're making one day i
think max i will be able to do a day
wow
really let me dead ass bro
no no nothing just asylum padding
padding in a bed i think i'll make it a
day oh
now i think i could probably make it
like three days maybe i think you'll be
surprised you know
i think you might be surprised james
i'm not gonna lie to you
i definitely ain't making 21 days oh i i
know i'm not making it that guy's a
[ __ ] animal has he made it that far
incentive bro he's banked 260 bags
true
that's incentive that is incentive that
is incentive
but still
that's a long time bro that was a
[ __ ] long-ass time long i don't think
i could do it
i genuinely think
24 hours would be my max i wouldn't make
more than 15 bags
i wouldn't i don't think so i mean
genuine really i mean genuine yeah
that's interesting to me i just don't
think even if you were just reading
books
i the thing with me is
i feel like
when i'm when i'm in my own space i'm
like well
when i'm chilling at home for example
let's say for example i'm on my phone
um i'll be scrolling through all
scrolling for scrolling through and then
my mind will just wander
you know so i'll just i will lose track
of whatever i'm doing yeah and then i'll
get probably get back into let's say i'm
in the in the thing and i'm reading the
book i'll be reading reading reading
i'll probably read about two pages and
be like
you know
because there's only scored adhd bro
there's only so much you can read
there's only so of yes you can read the
whole thing there's only i just get this
i'll get distracted
it sounds like you need this
i might see it all get just it's only
messing with two pages
i didn't just breathe
fam this is long
this is like i can't even look up and
see surroundings brother just all white
padding
[ __ ] it out
oh bro but at least you was like you're
sleeping at least eight to ten of those
hours away
am i though i'll probably sleep around
six
purely because no i'm being genuine i'm
being genuine i believe you because
you're not doing anything exactly if i'm
not doing anything my body doesn't need
that much rest yeah i'll be exercising
in there i'd be excellent i'll try
something i would probably exercise
that's why i said i think i'll make it
the first day
because i'll do as much as i could
throughout the whole day yeah i'd
exercise i'd bring i'd read everything
they try and give me
i don't know i don't know what i'll be
doing apart from that that one day i'll
be done bro really i think i'll be done
the only i think the only thing that
will keep me going
is if
after every day they show me my bank
account and they show me that the seven
and a half is in there yeah every single
day
at the end of 21 days here's your 260.
yeah yeah that might be the only
incentive your visual aids sweep me bro
that's what i need to survive i don't
think you understand
that's why you need to see it to believe
it or rags in any situation we've ever
had right oh it's so [ __ ] funny
anytime i've given you like an imaginary
scenario yeah you've always said show me
show me the numbers show me this show me
that i need to see he's just talking
you're just chatting [ __ ] right now
prove it yeah yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ] it up oh that's funny now i reckon
i would make it about three days
i i would start to lose my [ __ ] once
like
someone asked me like how long do you
think you've been in here and i'm like i
don't know
i if as soon as i think it could be a
week yeah it could be
a [ __ ] it could be three weeks i
actually don't know
then i'll be like yeah i'm done yeah
yeah yeah so i'd love to think
they'll be like how long you've been how
long do you think you've been in there
you'd probably say you said you might
last week you'd probably say about six
days they look at you big man it's been
two and a half fem it's been 12 hours
they could never tell me that i'd be
banging on or get me the [ __ ] out of
this [ __ ] there's a um
there's uh i can't remember what the
[ __ ] experiment there's a basically a
prison experiment i've watched the
uh
documentary i didn't actually watch the
documentary they made it into a feature
film but i um
they made it into a feature film but i
watched the feature film but i wish i
watched the documentary and i can't
remember what it's called but it's the
something experiment prison experiment
or something like that okay where they
take these college kids
they take half of them and let the and
tell them they're going to be god
they're never allowed to break character
okay half of them are guards okay half
of them are prisoners
age range do you say they're kids
they're college kids college kids okay
uh uh well uni okay okay okay so they're
like 18 18 19 20 yeah and bro they lose
they they
become these roles oh is it they become
these roles
bro
bro
they become these roles and these the
officers just
switch uh shifts okay all the time yeah
the officers really become the robot i'm
not surprised they start [ __ ] hating
the prisoners i'm not surprised power
player treating them like [ __ ] of course
the prisoners start [ __ ] hating the
thing and like
the mind games like they break down
mentally and they they forget it's an
experiment yeah after a couple weeks
these men think they're prisoners what's
the
basis of the experiment um just to see
like what psychologically what happens
to someone if you treat them like a
prisoner okay um
and like same with the gods what happens
to like a kid if you like you you give
him like fake power over people and see
if he actually starts to literally abuse
the power and [ __ ] fair enough um bro it
was it's a [ __ ] wild one these all go
mad and then once you let them out
they're like
i'll swear
they're like bro you've been in there
for like two weeks you know fam i'm not
gonna like some of the manual coming out
of that thing fam i thought i've been in
there for four years
they're not even joking they're
literally being daily serious big
manifold's in it for four [ __ ] years
like what's going on i haven't seen
daylight i was in [ __ ] daylight oh
one time the guys lost their [ __ ] and
just took everyone's mattresses that's
when [ __ ] got crazy oh my god i took the
mattresses that's when people went loopy
oh i can imagine you had that's where
man
you can imagine my mattress
this is a game first and foremost
this is a [ __ ] game don't take my
mattress bro when they couldn't sleep
that's when you see my losing their
[ __ ] patience
oh i need to watch this thing oh bro i'm
trying to find it for you i need to
watch this my god that's jokes yeah as
soon as man takes your your ability to
sleep yeah
you're you're a different brother all
right that's when um i always think
about like when they when they talk
about like prisoners of war and like
torture and stuff like that and like
what would make you break and the
techniques they use to make people break
some of them fam
i will spill the beans so very quickly
so very quickly
bro as soon as they deprive me of sleep
because apparently what they'll do in
some of them is they'll literally like
they'll let you sleep but only for like
two hours at a time
so don't show you daylight they'll show
you anything bro and then they'll just
let you doze off they'll leave you there
for like an hour two hours until you're
deep in it and they'll wake up like
heavy metal
and they'll have heavy metal playing
[ __ ] loud in there for hours so you
just can't go sleep
you can't sleep
it's going to be vexed
that's going to be that will
psychologically change after a couple
days that will change breaks man
it breaks man i'm not [ __ ] surprised
man without sleep
will do anything
i promise you this is outrageous yeah
fam
if i hadn't slept in three days and only
man only let me sleep an hour at a time
yeah and i'm not joking if a [ __ ]
russian warlord just walked in asked
naked and said suck me off and i'll let
you see 12 hours
i'll gobble it
i wouldn't think twice at that point if
i'm three days deprived bro
i'll gobble it
[Laughter]
i'll gobble the ting hands and knees oh
whatever he tells me to do ah i need
sleep and he offers me 12 hours
uninterrupted not even freedom sleep wow
you might have sucked dick for anything
are you telling me you wouldn't because
you love sleep i love sleep james
three [ __ ] days you haven't slept i
know you've been hearing this slipknot
red hot chili peppers just loud in your
ear they won't let you sleep every time
your head dozes someone wakes up into
smacks in your face listen to me james
listen to me i
promise you i would snap out of this
whole experiment thing i will grab a
guard
i will grab a guard by his collarbone i
promise you
i'll grab them and say [ __ ] switch
positions now switch rolls now yeah fam
because i'm tired of this prisoner [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah bro i'm telling you
three days no sleep
man comes in with a fat dick and says
swap it
and will let you keep the kippiest of
kids like
like my man from that little kid from um
not a little kid like a teenager from
what's that what's that show called the
night of
the night oh god the fat lip yeah
he had luscious lips on him in it it's
actually mad he got he got scouted
luscious lips
he had the dicky sucky lips i've seen
bro it's not even it's actually dread
but it's not even surprising that
homeboy recruited him for his throat
yeah oh my god it was dread for him yeah
yeah yeah i'm saying like he rocks up
and just says fam slop this top and
you'll have the sleepiest sleep oh my
god three days we had i don't even get
it three [ __ ] days james i care i get
it but i promise you i'm grabbing a
guard by his chest this is no longer an
experiment i'm saying if you're an
actual prisoner
i'm a prisoner yeah i'm a full-time
person you're a full look you're a
prisoner of war
this is torture for you okay and this is
no this isn't a college experiment i'm
not sucking anyone's taking a college
experiment i say let me the [ __ ] out
i forgot my human rights let me the [ __ ]
out
you've got your human rights in jail as
well no yeah
they see man like you before yeah yeah
yeah
yeah so i'm saying
three days you ain't slept
you're not you know that could be on
knackered you're having hallucinations
bro
and every time you drop off you hear
slipknot
it wakes you up and you wake up to a
[ __ ] hand in your face
smack
and then humble just walks out
james
james you're tired your hands are tired
and my hands my hands have to be tired
the chair's bouncing ah my hand's
happening
because i'm biting someone
i don't think you understand if i grab
you yeah i'm biting yeah
if you can't do nothing your hands are
chained your feet are chained okay tears
bounces yeah every two hours some smacks
you in your [ __ ] face and walks out
so i'm giving top like this
yeah
i'm giving top chained up chained up you
don't have to is that you can carry on
there's not where there's no sleeping
[ __ ]
or you can suck me off and you'll sleep
every day that you're here how long am i
here for until we say leave
but we're not gonna kill you or torture
you anymore but you're gonna be here
it's prison for you now but suck me off
and you're going to kip and your eyes
are beyond bloodshot
you can't see
you can't see am i sucking to completion
i don't know what you're doing you're
sucking you're giving it
that's up to his discretion
okay so your suck is sucking until he
either nuts yeah or
he just like
you're any yeah to him yeah and he's uh
you know what i'm not gonna nut
babe
stop babe
yeah
to be fair
pun is pun intended i have to bite the
bullet i would
i would agree to suck in the tool yeah
yeah but sam i want you know them ones
where they say
you've been clapping cheeks clapping
cheeks and scenes or clap cheeks
insinuates you're hitting it more than
once yeah yeah yeah i would do the
singular club i'll clap so i would suck
it once
break and then again no no no no i'll
suck it once and clam down on it i'd
[ __ ] bite his dick off
i'd bite his [ __ ] dick off and you
might do what you want with me i'm done
shoot me kill me whatever i'm done
they're not gonna kill you they just
won't let you sleep ever again that's
fine he's he's not got a dick ever again
yeah but he's one guard this is a
complex
you think they give a [ __ ] about him he
just wanted the blowy from a guy
they wanted sleep for you yeah they were
tired of torturing you
so they said one rarity they can try me
they can try me you're searching three
days bro i don't think you understand
the mental state you're in i know he's
offering you gold
it's funny that you think this let's
move on it's funny that you think this
guy's in the comments let us know how
long you think this is my name yeah you
ain't been let us know how long you
asked
you ain't been sleep deprived like that
why should i be i'm just saying i said
i've i've been sleep deprived and just
from the little experience i've had on
it i know i'm sucking tall for three
days because i've been i've had like 24.
yeah times up by three i can't imagine
what will be going on in my mind
i can't imagine the nightmares i'll be
the living nightmares i'll be
experienced i'll suck at all
very [ __ ] the man said your bite is
dick off and let these man just keep you
awake forever silly little boy
you're a silly little boy with a silly
little dream
[Laughter]
guys in the comments let us know how
long you think yeah how many days do you
think you're saying
yeah seven and a half bags every single
day how long will you make it all right
but
[ __ ] me that was funny all right you got
a question for me no oh yes i've
completely forgot about that i do have a
question for you
right
your girl is pregnant in the hospital
and is about to give birth to your first
child but your closest boy i.e me
has just been hurt and i might not make
it i'm in a completely different
hospital 30 minutes away who are you
going to you
swear yeah
it's a silly question
i'm not lying to you it's a stupid
question
why because
being there for your your child's first
like being there for the birth of your
child is all well and good
but i'm never going to see you again
i'm going to see this you every [ __ ]
day i can make it up to it you know what
i mean and you don't even [ __ ] know
yeah yeah yeah you don't know she'll
know obviously yeah [ __ ] her
she'll know i don't care
he's dead
he's [ __ ] dead and i dare have to
pipe up
he's my bedroom and he died and he
needed me there and i wasn't [ __ ]
there and i'm never ever gonna get that
back
i'm with you [ __ ] every day
every day i see you
we can have more use i could be there
for their birth fair enough this is my
bridge and he's gone fair enough all
right your selfish ass is chatting about
your damn self and your contractions oh
stop
and you're dilation
he's gone that's fair fair enough what
would you do i'll say more yeah no
brainer no i wouldn't think about it
bro
no brainer i'll be straight in the way
yeah as soon as i hear i'm running out i
would be it's hard to ask a woman
because obviously he won't be their
partner you know so it's weird unless
obviously they do um what's the thing
i'm talking about i don't know what
you're doing about obviously
lesbian coupling they do the
insemination the ivf ivf that one that
thing okay
so yeah obviously she can then have the
choice that's what i'm saying if you're
if i was asking a woman this question
because her female partner was having a
baby as well as her brethren in the
hospital who would you go to i think you
see i mean okay that's what i'm saying i
don't know if it would differ if it's a
woman i don't i don't know i don't know
i don't know i don't think so bro i
don't know um right let's do aji
questions bro let's um right guys so
last week
we asked you
huh what's the shadiest thing you've
ever done
and yeah as per usual guys you guys hit
us up with the juiciest responses so
here we go oh okay i i just only just
clocked what you just said yeah this
what's the shadiest thing what's the
shadiest thing you've ever done i
already know this one's wild what's the
shadiest thing you've ever done oh [ __ ]
you know all right
told his baby mama stuff that she could
use against him in court
wow
yeah bro
yeah wow
yeah funny no i won't say it
okay funny yeah i'll tell you off camera
um this is this podcast is an open book
yeah there's just certain things i
shouldn't say i say less
okay okay okay
someone pissed me off so i'll put their
number in a pay to text sex app which
cost 10 per text to send and receive he
got bagger messages
and they just charged him a tenner every
time every single time
how do you
unsubscribe
that's
now
subscribe
earlier
double jeopardy
signed him up to a fake std positive
message to disturb his peace after he
cheated on me
his piece was disturbed i best believe
that it was because his mind was going
crazy yes yes
yes can i tell what do i say yes should
i just pattern it yes
is she infected like what's going on she
would have seen him that day acting
shady 100 percent and she would just
been giggling can you imagine if she did
that yeah she saw him see it see his
reaction and then he tried to bang her
that night
can you imagine she'll stab him
she would literally stab it
how dare you he's thinking she's got it
anyway
she's got it anyway it's the only way
i'm gonna sleep tonight
i need this off me jokes
uh an old friend done me die so i
reported her car to the dvla for not
having any tax
what's wrong with people fam shade
what the [ __ ] is wrong with people
family
aborted his kid and told him via text
that's not even funny
fam
carry on
stole from everyone in my friendship
group planted it on a guy who just had
to go [ __ ] him
wow
had to go [ __ ] him that's what she said
well i'd love to know who this guy was
jesus christ oh
bought a fake positive pregnancy so he
wouldn't leave me and she bought hee hee
see i've mentioned this
i've mentioned all these
yeah ad-libs and these these salsa teams
hear these emojis [ __ ] you man
so he wouldn't leave me he he
his dick was so ugly that i pretended my
phone was ringing so i could leave
not even on a give me a minute type
thing so i could leave
rocks fair enough i wouldn't even say
this if that's the shadiest thing
someone's done that's not bad
ran away from ugly dick
fam but yeah fair enough anyway called a
girl's mother and told her that her
daughter had just had an abortion when i
was in high school
wow why would you do that
literally why would you do that shade
rush she probably ellipse to her man or
so he's stupid like that [ __ ]
was black tower and peed on his clean
laundry and blamed it on his dog
[ __ ]
reported my ex to his probation officer
so he only had one more violation before
jail time
didn't even do anything
probably not
probably not he probably pissed her off
a little that's it
oh i can't handle these
i heard my roommate talk [ __ ] about me
so i popped her back tires and made her
late for an exam
bro i i'm not really enjoying i thought
these were going to be bare funny but
actually just making me bro
uncomfortable
it's dark yeah it's not even on i asked
my boyfriend to say
this is the one i think i said to you
earlier i asked my boyfriend to send me
money for my course but i spent it on
vacation with my girls
this is the salsa thing
what a [ __ ]
what a what an absolute [ __ ] family you
didn't even say that they sent the money
thing
no this i think there was two separate
ones oh there's two separate ones oh
okay
the salsa one i already posted okay i
posted a reply so this is similar
jesus man yeah
purposely pulled out strands of my hair
and left it in his bathtub so his
girlfriend could find it
you plucked your own follicles to leave
in the bar for next woman to find and
do you know the actual maddest thing
about that is that she knew that she
would find it of course i would never
see that if i'm here if it's little in
and out of that shower
la dee
da she knew that a girl would find it
bro i used to date a girl
who used to leave hair clips under my
pillow
for herself to find to confront me with
no she never i promised you she no she
never i promise you she did and every
time i would be like big man it's yours
and she would always say the thing is
she did one time too many which made me
knew she'd [ __ ] up
made me know she [ __ ] up bro
she always used to say brother these
clips are brown i only wear black
she said that
multiple times but then i'm pretty sure
at one point she flipped it ah
i was like brother this one's black i
only wear brown and i was like hang on
last time you said it was brown you only
wear black she was like
no
i'm like yeah
i'm fairly [ __ ] certain yeah
and then i didn't really i hadn't had
enough experience with women not
everyone wears these [ __ ] clips yeah
yeah yeah yeah not everyone wears these
same stupid little
ziggy zaggy [ __ ] tweezer looking
clothes grips whatever you [ __ ] call
them bro i should have called her out
man yeah but i wasn't confident enough i
was thinking maybe there was a hoe in my
head i can't remember i don't even know
oh he's just stressing me out
if the sex was trash i would steal
something random from their house
just consistently
this is not even i say it isn't
oh my god
my friend felt like her man had another
girl i was giving her advice i was the
other girl
women will do this consistently
will bang their best friend's man
consistently
he has two kids and hiv don't [ __ ] with
me
what
that's exactly what i said brother i
don't even know what what he has two
kids and hiv don't [ __ ] with me
she get she gave him the ting brother
what she gave him the tit
what yes
you heard what i said brother don't she
she she confessed by saying don't [ __ ]
with me
don't [ __ ] with me she did not give him
hiv
she did
gave mates
wow
got head in a hostel toilet it was so
bad that i squeezed out a bit of wee and
pretending i finished to make it stop
to make it stop not even to tell her to
stop to make it stop
bro
squeezed out a bit of weed how fam i
have no he must have squeezed oh that's
a [ __ ] stop bro you see that we're in
a hostel for god
not even a hostel a hostile toilet oh
jesus the worst of the worst
took a couple hundred out of his wallet
and replaced it with a few of my dollars
rent was due
family
found out my ex was cheating
two days before his holiday so i cut the
id page out of his passport no you
[ __ ] didn't i cut the id page out of
his passport
these lot we've said this before we said
it on the on the thing this morning
these not move like there are no
consequences to the actions that you're
doing facts spread out and they think if
my heart's broken i will do whatever i
want because it's justifiable you break
my heart big man big man my heart is
priceless
this 10 grand holiday that you're going
on whatever your business your business
you should have thought about that
before you cheated anyway no i shouldn't
have
no i shouldn't have i don't have to
think about this
cut the id page out of his password
these things wouldn't even enter my mind
it would never cross my hemisphere i
promise you that's not
i would never think of that i'll just
leave
i'll just [ __ ] leave
what's this revenge thing i'm tired of
revenge for you oh it's too much it's
too much women are so vengeful they are
they are
just stop just leave me bruv listen
smashed my friend's baby daddy just to
prove to her i could have it all
[Laughter]
what
your friend are you sure
just to prove to her i could have it all
who the [ __ ] i sometimes i hear these
bro and i can't believe they're actually
people that sent them to us oh brother i
read them every single time and my mind
is blown every single time
just to prove i could have it all to
your own friend
wow
messaged my ex two days before my
wedding to see if there was anything
still there oh my god did a guy send
that a girl sent that really yes brother
i knew you think a guy said that that's
what i was waiting for you to ask a girl
sent that
wow exactly [ __ ] no fam these girls
are livid they're livid and they're
[ __ ]
like you said they don't care about
consequence a lot of these ones i've
read i've all been women yeah
the next one
went to brunch with another man on my
man's birthday
brunch
i robbed the priest's car oh my [ __ ]
god
[ __ ] here now told his very religious
family that he cheated on me with a guy
why
oh god i just need to understand why i
brought i need to ask one of them why
why why why why are you doing this i
moved to spain instead of locking it
with my needy boyfriend oh jesus christ
he would have broken down that's not
even shady he would have broken down oh
my god you've killed someone he would
have broken down
he cheated on me
so on his birthday i had a cake made
with a photo of her face on it
that would have that would have changed
his world yeah that's not even shady
that's like see that i can understand
that's not revenge that's not that's
just face up
yeah that's you blindsided him and he
has to come clean
when you're in positions where there are
no more ways out you just have to just
just
you got it
in it
you [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] that's jokes
that's hilarious there's like buttermilk
oh that's hilarious that's hilarious
i pretended to be asleep on the bus
because i didn't want to give my seat to
an old lady on crutches my god
jesus that's evil
took my life took my friend's last
tenner and he oh let me start again
sorry took my friend's last tenor after
you dropped it and helped him look for
it for an hour
that's like me when i thieved
that's the first thing i thought yeah
last one
a guy came in my mouth but i found it so
disgusting so i spat it back in his
[ __ ] spat it back in his
but yeah that's it that's it for today
guys you managed that one was
dodgy
that one was weird and i don't know how
to feel about that one i when you when
you started it i thought it's going to
be the funniest thing i've ever heard
and then it's just like it just went
inside into human nature and you're like
wow i've lost all faith in humanity yeah
it was different
it was different because friends are
betraying friends
girls are betraying guys guys between
girls yes
it wasn't really enjoyable
it was west
wow okay but yeah anyway guys thank you
very much for for sticking with us today
um we hope to see you on thursday over
at patreon standard um so head on over
there now if you can sign up get ready
for the next episode but in the meantime
guys as always love love love again
[Music]